so there's word right now that Warner  Brothers Discovery is trying to tee  itself up for yet another merger looking  to be bought by Comcast there's a lot to  fit into a minute but I'm going to do my  best first off because of regulatory  reasons if this even happens it can't  happen any earlier than 2024 and  actually it would be such a big merger  of previously competing companies that  it might finally be enough for the  government to step in and go no that's  too big you can't do that but it would  actually make a certain amount of sense  in regards to what David sassle of  current CEO of Warner Brothers Discovery  has been doing because a lot of people  are questioning a lot of his decisions  and a lot of them would make at least a  little bit more sense through the lens  of he's trying to streamline the company  to make it more appealing for sale  something something capitalism bad  God